good evening London welcome to pibg on
sensitive 5 days ago terrorists from
Hamas attacked Israel they murdered and
raped civilians they executed the
elderly at bus stops they took babies
and Holocaust Survivors as hostages and
they massacred young people at a
festival they may it emerged last night
have even beheaded babies in one Village
more than 12200 Israelis are now
believed to have died and this brutal
attack has dragged Israel into war
Israel had every right to respond with
Force as it done the death toll in Gaza
is now more than a thousand and many
more will die many of those will be
completely innocent people like those
who died in Hamas attacks like almost
everyone I've been shocked and sickened
by the stories and videos emerging from
the attack I've Al also been stunned by
the moral cowardice of those who
celebrated Terror as resistance and
brutality as politics I've called out
the people who've confed a terror attack
with a geopolitical debate and I've
spoken to fair-minded people on both
sides of that debate I've done all this
as a journalist and a human being but
with no personal skin in the game my
guest tonight on the other hand is one
of the most prominent and influential
Jewish commentators on the planet Ben
Shapiro has been visibly moved and
enraged by the tragedies unfolding in
Israel and the world has paid attention
to his analysis tonight I'm giving the
show to him as we tackle all the big
questions that have come out of this
what is a proportionate response to
terrorism should the United States be
more involved how do we move forward if
everyone involved sees the other side as
an oppressor or a Savage and M Del wise
Ben Shapiro joins me now Ben uh great to
have you on the program I wish it was
under different circumstances I want to
ask you first of all where were you when
you first heard about these
attacks so I'd been in Israel for
several weeks and we had just gotten
home to uh to the United States on
Friday morning uh Friday night obviously
is Sabbath for for orthodox Jews and it
also happened to be one of the biggest
celebratory days of the
year was a a two-day what we call yum
which means no electricity really you
can't use your phone you can't use your
computer uh my security team showed up
at synagogue on Saturday morning and
started informing me of what had
happened and then news was was kind of
bleeding through throughout the day
there were various sources you know
Maids who were leaving TVs on for
example or my security team informing me
throughout the weekend of what exactly
was happening because of the serious
security concerns that arise for Jews
all over the planet when there's Mass
terror attack in Israel or or anywhere
else and um and so you know we were
finding out in uh a lagged time what
exactly was happening obviously we
couldn't watch the videos we couldn't
see exactly what was happening until it
came back online on Sunday night and
we're hit with the news that at that
point 700 Jews have been murdered today
that number is has been totaled at well
over 1,200 Jews have been murdered in in
Israel we started to see all of the
pictures on our TVs uh I obviously
because I'm in touch with with a lot of
people on the the ground First
Responders uh people on the ground in
Israel I started receiving extraordinary
levels of of footage and and video and
audio and and pictures of what exactly
had happened in these places and um yeah
I mean these are these are images i'
I've been trying to show them to the
audience for for one very specific
reason uh and that specific reason is to
to to understand what evil is you have
to look in the face of evil and I I
think that you know we in the west have
a A peculiar narcissism that we everyone
thinks like we do uh that that we value
children in a certain way and so
everyone values children in a certain
way that that if somebody does something
truly terrible or evil it must be that
there was something that quote unquote
drove them to it must be a policy
question um but as it turns out that
that is not the case because there's
literally nothing I think there that
could drive people in in the west a
normal person to go and to murder a baby
in their crib uh in in a civilian area
to to simply walk in and gun down
grandmothers or to rape a woman and drag
her back to the Gaza Strip what what
could drive you to do that I can't think
of anything that would drive me to do
that but a lot of people who are not
only driven to do that but but Believe
full well in the virtue of what they're
doing that is a different mode of
thought and that is not something you
can negotiate with you've seemed about
this for completely understandable
reasons to have been more enraged than I
think I've ever seen you almost like a
simmering volcano as you've talked about
this I want to play a clip from your
daily wire YouTube channel you have 6
million subscribers and this is part of
what was I thought a very powerful
address that you made
there I am a Jew
those have been the words of the Jewish
people for three Millennia those were
the words of the men women and children
of Masada those were the words of the
followers of Barba those were the words
of Jews and Granada in 1066 and the
reinland in 1096 and ketki from 1648 to
1657 and kishinev in 1903 and kevron in
1929 those were the words of Jews in
aitz and trinka those were the last
words of Daniel Pearl and those are my
words too they're the words of my
parents the words of my my wife my
children over the weekend my people the
Jewish people were attacked and murdered
mutilated our women were raped our
children were
kidnapped this happened millions of
times before to millions of Jews across
history Jew hatred exists because evil
exists because there are people who have
for literally all of human history hated
the Jews and sought to strike at them
while they are weak who have blamed the
Jews for their own problems who have
crafted complex conspiracy theories
about the supposed power of the Jews who
have sought to destroy to murder to
mutilate to rape the Jews from pharaoh
to hmon from Hitler to
Kamas what reaction have you had to that
Ben I think the reaction has been pretty
strong and and overwhelmingly positive I
think there there are a lot of people
not only Jews mostly my audience is
people who are not Jewish obviously who
who understand the history of the Jewish
people who understand what it means when
when the greatest Slaughter of Jews on a
mass scale happens since the Holocaust
and and who understand that it is
inextricably linked to a history of
anti-Semitism that goes back thousands
of years I mean this extermination level
anti-Semitism what you see from Hamas
it's literally part of their Charter and
so the attempt to treat them as a normal
political body obviously is foolish I
think that a lot of people resonated to
that it's the certainly the strongest I
felt about anything that happened in my
lifetime since 911 um as an American
since 911 and as a Jew obviously I I'm
I'm watching as people that I know
people I'm friends with are getting
called up to go to the military and
serve in Gaza try to protect the the
Israeli citizenry who are Jews and Arabs
who are Christians and Jews and Muslims
and um and you know I'm watching as you
know there there are people out there
who are rallying on behalf of of actual
terrorist groups murdering children I
mean it's an amazing it's an amazing I
would say exposure of of ignorance at at
at best ignorance at best and Jew hatred
at worst do you have any personal
connection to anyone who whose life was
taken uh I don't uh I'm I'm I'm lucky I
would say that I I have um certainly I
know a lot of people who do so the way
to to talk about the Jewish community in
general there are not very many Jews on
the planet uh due to conspiracy theories
people tend to think there are tens of
millions of Jews on the planet the grand
total number of Jews on planet Earth is
about 15 million about 7 million who
live in the state of Israel about six
million who live in the United States
and what that means is that in general
Society you think you know seven degrees
of Kevin Bacon with with seven degrees
of of connection you can find anyone in
among among Jews that that's one that
number one so I I certainly know an
enormous number of people who uh who
have had people who were kidnapped
who've had people who were murdered I
certainly know personally enormous
number of people who are on the ground
right now I know Americans who are who
are in Israel with me who decided to
stay over the last day of the omt over
the over the holiday and ended up
basically getting stuck there because
the the airport was shut down because of
Rocket attacks and uh and when the call
went out to everybody with medical
training to to show up to to help I know
American doctors who showed up at the
Gaza border to Simply set up triage
stations and help people out so I mean
it is it's a very small community it's a
very close net Community obviously
you've spoken a lot about Hamas before
uh called them evil uh you did a second
video called make God avenge their blood
in which you said that Hamas in some
ways they are worse the Nazis which some
viewed as a very provocative statement
why did you say that about them the the
Nazis I mean here's a phrase I'll never
use again at least the Nazis so at least
the Nazis attempted to hide their crimes
and so so the Nazis obviously mechanized
death they had inet grp group in units
that they drove up to to Jewish villages
and would mow people down um and then
they would bury them and they would try
to hide the crimes and it took you know
the nberg team years to to undig all of
that material in this particular case
you have Hamas terrorists who are
murdering Jews in their beds and live
streaming it and and celebrating it and
bragging about it and and talking about
how incredible it is and Blasting that
sort of stuff out I mean the videos that
I've been showing on my show a lot of
them are coming directly from Kamas I
mean it's Kamas that that is taking
contemporaneous video of this sort of
stuff and that that's a whole new level
of evil that to to celebrate this sort
of stuff to treat it as a Triumph I mean
I think the thing that that that people
really have to realize here is this is
not a military operation this was not a
military operation I mean people have
compared this to ex for example the 1973
y Kor war that was an awful moment in
Israel's history when it was taken by
surprise by the combined Arab armies
around it but that was a military
operation with a military objective
which was to seize territory this is not
a military operation with a military
objective this was this was an operation
directed specifically at civilians and
and when we see death in Gaza which
we're going to see and the images are
going to be horrifying and terrible it
is important to understand that the
reason that that is happening is not
just because Hamas crossed the border
and murdered a bunch of civilians in
their beds but also because Hamas
literally hides its Weaponry behind
civilians Israel is currently right now
sending out messages to gazin civilians
telling them to get out of particular
areas and Hamas is sending out full
scale messages telling people to ignore
those messages and to stay where they
are Hamas is is they there's a reason
why their headquarters were for years
located underneath a hospital mean it's
the the the what they what they they
understand that the West again has a
peculiar narcissism where we think we
would never put our military our
military hardware below a hospital
that'd be insane um and so if Israel
blows up a hospital it must be that
Israel is doing that because they're
targeting civilians Kamas knows that
that's that's why they're doing it
that's why they're doing it they
literally hide their rocket launchers
behind apartment buildings in the hope
that Israel will strike back and have to
kill civilians in the process Israel
cares significantly more about civilian
casualties in Gaza than Hamas ever has
one of the I mean there have been so
many horrendous uh images and videos the
poor girl from The Music Festival taken
away on the motorbike was just bone
chilling to watch um I I saw something
on CNN yesterday with Jake Tapper where
he's interviewing the relative of a
grandmother his grandmother who was
murdered and Hamas posted the video of
her being murdered onto her Facebook
page so her family would watch it
I mean when you hear that it's sort of
unconscionable it's it's kind of Beyond
depravity this is
inhumanity I mean Piers you're in the
business of words and I'm in the
business of words and I've found myself
repeatedly over the last few days unable
to to find words to describe the kind of
thing that we're seeing and again we we
stretch I think in the west and I
stretch as an American we I think we all
stretch to try and find you know what
would drive somebody to do something
like this and the answer sometimes is
that they are just they're I don't know
how to say this otherwise they are not
like you Hamas is not like you they
don't think like you they don't have the
same priorities as you they don't have
the same values as you and that means
that any attempt to buy them off is is
bound to fail and and this is
inextricably intertwined with the
history I mean the fact is Israel turned
over the Gaza Strip in 2005 there were
no Jews living in the Gaza Strip since
2005 the areas that were attacked in
this particular terrorist attack are not
areas that are in the so-called
settlements theim in Judea Samaria
What's called the West Bank that that
that's not the area that was attacked
the areas that was attacked has been
Sovereign Israeli territory since
1947-48 and and that territory was
attacked from across a border that is
entirely controlled by Hamas which has
utilized pretty much every dollar that
has that has flooded into that region
over the course of 20 years from America
from EUR taxpayer dollars that have been
used to build up these Terror
capabilities and every time there cement
shipments into into the the area ruled
by Hamas Hamas has used it to build
Terror tunnels pipes that have been sent
into the area ruled by Hamas that were
meant to build sewage systems have been
repurposed and used for for Rocket tubes
I mean this is this is in it's it's
utterly insane and to to try and come up
with some sort of territorial solution
this is really just a territorial
dispute it is not a terror territorial
dispute it is is a genocidal group that
makes clear its own intentions I don't
know how many times people have to tell
you who they are before you believe them
the reason that I've been saying that
Hamas is genocidal for literally my
entire career is because they say in
their own founding documents that they
are
genocidal it's not as though they're
attempting to avoid cability
responsibility for this they are saying
it out loud they're begging you to take
them seriously also they're also
terrorists I mean let's just be crystal
clear this is an act of terrorism that
we saw at the weekend the worst since
9/11 one of the worst Terror attacks in
modern history and yet you have
mainstream media the BBC in Britain
refusing to describe Hamas as terrorists
they call them militants even John
Simson one of their senior foreign
correspondents and editors said it's not
a journalist role to call groups like
Hamas terrorists he says calling someone
a terrorist means you're taking sides
and ceasing to treat the situation with
due impartiality the BBC's job is to
place the facts before his audience and
let them decide what they think honestly
and without ranting that's why in
Britain throughout the world nearly half
a billion watch listen to and read us
there's always someone who'd like us to
rant sorry it's not what we do but I
don't think it's about ranting to
describe acts of Terror as being
committed by terrorists and the New York
Times apparent ly today actually changed
uh the wording of a story they they put
online and changed the word Hamas
terrorist to Hamas gunmen as if they're
almost terrified you know literally I
mean how ironic of using the word
terrorist but what is it about
mainstream media two huge examples of it
New York Times and the BBC that they
won't just call this what it
is I think that that a lot of these
groups are afraid of the political
implications of of just calling
a terrorist to terrorist I mean when
when you acknowledge that the government
of of the Gaza Strip is in fact a
terrorist government that has some
pretty large scale implications for a
lot of the political agendas at play
because of course the the great sort of
dream of of the West since at least the
oso courts has been that territorial
concessions and that economic
concessions would would solve this
problem when it turns out that an entire
area is governed by a a government that
is in fact a terrorist government it's
an actual terrorist group uh then that
has some pretty significant implications
moving forward for the prospects in the
region and it also suggests that Israel
has a moral duty which it absolutely
does to protect its own citizenry by
eviscerating that terrorist group from
the planet and the word terrorist has a
definition and that definition by any
stretch of the imagination is fulfilled
by by what Kamas is I mean the BBC's
explanation is so bizarre it's almost
like suggesting that if you found a a
man who had murdered his wife in an
apartment and you reported on that you
didn't call it murder you just said that
some someone was killed a person was
killed and and and the person was
convicted of murder and you still said
Mur we we don't make judgments over here
and use language like the word murderer
because that would carry some moral
implication well yes it turns out that
murdering entire families slaughtering
entire families burning them I mean some
of the stuff that I've been that I've
been tweeting out which is stuff I'm
getting again directly from First
Responders on the ground I mean just a
few moments ago I tweeted out I wish I
didn't have to tweet out these photos
but I think people need to understand
the consequences of failing to see evil
for what it is it was a it was a photo
of some a group of people in in a kaboot
called kabut B which is again near the
border where 100 bodies were found and
they were attempting to Simply escape
and Hamas stop the car and burn these
people alive I don't know how you don't
call
that what other goal could you have but
to obscure the morality of the
situation if if you refuse to call
things what what they are I don't it's
it boggles the mind it really it truly
does I mean what also boggled the mind
for me was uh black lives matter Chicago
which had a Twitter account with 60,000
followers they actually posted a
caricature image of a paraglider saying
I stand with Palestine the paragliders
were of course were the ones who flew in
and killed all the people at the music
festival what did you feel when you saw
that I mean unsurprising only in the
sense that black lives matter as as an
organization had all sorts of solidarity
statements about Palestine going all the
way back to the the original movement in
2014 2015 um but the but seeing them
actively take up the the imagery of an
actual terrorist attack that's what that
is Palestinians are not famous for their
for their hangliding and the only reason
why that is the image is because literal
terrorists use paragliders in order to
murder civilians at an electronic dance
music festival by the way attended
mostly by people of the political left I
mean those are not right-wing Israelis
who are dancing at an EDM Festival on on
a Saturday that's not the way that works
um it's it it's only astonishing in
either the moral blindness or the
anti-Semitism and at a certain point the
moral blindness becomes the
anti-Semitism because when you are
celebrating active Jew murder and you
are saying that that's solidarity that's
a pretty incredible thing I'd also like
to point out here that the argument in
favor of Palestinian self-determination
did not need to be threatened by any of
these people all they could have said is
Hamas does not represent Palestinians
this does not have any implications for
Palestinian self-determination Hamas is
a terrorist group and they ought to be
eviscerated and they ought to be
replaced by a better government that
could make peace with none of this is
particularly hard the fact that they're
lumping together Hamas with the
Palestinian cause says an awful lot and
it doesn't say anything good in one of
the videos you say the only solution is
for Israel to Annex the Gaza Strip and
kill enough sons of [__] to make sure
this isn't a problem again you say
anyone who calls for a ceasefire is a
terrorist sympathizer under these
circumstances now that got a lot of push
back uh I guess this comes to the point
of appropriate response how far do you
go how do you isolate genuine Hamas from
perhaps completely innocent Palestinians
in Gaza of which there will be many um
one person called you a genocidal
warmonger for that rhetoric and there's
a a person called Muhammad hijab and a
video called in responding to benj on
Israel he says
this first and foremost I'll say yes we
condemn any woman child or whatever it
may be that's being killed who's Jewish
and who's not a non-combatant but why is
it the case Ben huh why is it the case
that you none of your colleagues or you
have been able to offer one single
condolence one single condemnation one
single word of sympathy for any of the
gazin that have been killed don't try
and smear us don't try and slander us
don't try and attack don't try and
produce red earrings and I think you're
an ass a jackass and we're not talking
about Hamas we're talking about children
here we're talking about women here
we're talking about elderly
people you make me sick you make me
sick what's your response to that B that
will be I'm sure a reaction you have
heard from a lot of people what do you
feel about that I mean my obvious
response is of course I feel horrible
for the people who are being held by
Hamas in a state of tyranny for the past
15 years Hamas was the elected
government in Gaza in 2006 there hasn't
been an election since then all the
people who are who are today ranting as
as you heard Muhammad hijab doing right
there I don't hear them talking about
liberating Gaza from Hamas which is the
greatest threat to the to the way of
life of Gaza on planet Earth again I
have nothing but sympathy for Hamas for
for the people that Hamas is is
governing or the people that Hamas is
exploiting really I have nothing but
sympathy for civilians there Israel has
to defend itself I don't understand
exactly what the expectation would be
here is is the expectation that because
Hamas uses human Shields that Israel
therefore has to go home and wait to be
to to have its people murdered again
Israel tried it the way that that
Muhammad hijab and others would like
Israel literally pulled in 2005 they
literally pulled thousands of Jews out
of the Gaza Strip it was called the
disengagement and it was massively
unpopular in wide swats of Israel they
they pulled out they built a wall and
they basically said go ahead and govern
yourselves and this is the result of
that you think Israel you think I you
think anyone in Israel no one in Israel
wants to reoccupy the Gaza Strip no one
that's why Israel has been studiously
avoiding reoccupying the Gaza Strip
since 2006 despite the fact that theyve
been living underground in large parts
of Israel for weeks at a time because of
Rocket attacks have been fired on a
regular basis from the Gaz of strip into
major cities let me ask you let me ask
you this in Gaza you have two million
people many of whom are young people
pretty hopeless conditions to live in I
think people would agree with that uh
not much chance of getting out of there
uh they live in very densely populated
areas we know from in the last 24 hours
that Israel controls water controls
Energy power going in there uh many
would see that that is a control that
Israel shouldn't have have if you want
to afford equal rights to people living
in in Gaza and then it comes down to
proportionate response and how you try
and like I say how do you how do you
attack Hamas given they're all over Gaza
living amongst the general population
how do you attack and isolate genuine
members of Hamas genuine uh terrorists
from the civilian population and given
that is almost impossible clearly what
is a proportionate response to what's
happened here well I frankly I don't
believe in proportionate response to
terrorism I believe that the way that
you stop terrorism is with wildly
disproportionate response that doesn't
mean in terms of targeting civilians
means in terms of killing as many
terrorists as humanly possible and
allowing them to dictate the terms of
Engagement by hiding behind civilians in
areas that that they are supposedly
responsible for means that the only
option for Israel is to surrender to
hamas's hatred of its own citizens its
willingness to use its own children as
human Shields no no country worth its
salt could ever do that no no government
trying to protect its own citizens could
ever do that what exactly is the
alternative option other than for Israel
to try to kill as many of these
terrorists into post Hamas and hopefully
help put in place some sort of
International overseen Community that
would actually govern the Gaza Strip in
a in a rational reasonable way that
actually maximizes the possibilities of
its citizens Israel over the course of
the last year allowed some 15,000 work
permits to gsin many of those work
permits we're now finding out were used
by terrorists in order to cross the
border the fact that Israel controls the
water and the power the reason that
Israel controls the water and the power
is specifically because if they did not
control the water and the power Hamas
would be right now hold up with the
water and the power indefinitely I mean
the fact is that the reason that Israel
controls for example the seab border is
because if they did not there were
attempts to ship weapons in from Turkey
multiple times the the The Impossible
situation in which Israel finds itself
with regard to the Gaza Strip is
mirrored only by The Impossible
situation which in which Gaz and
civilians find themselves and all of
that every single iota of that is the
result of Hamas which means unless there
is a change in status in which is
removed from power in which someone else
is put in charge this is going to
continue
again 10,000 10,000 going into the to
defend their citizens I agree with you
but I would also say that I think that
it would also benefit any chance of a
peace settlement that if Netanyahu
wasn't in charge anymore um I mean apart
from anything else this is an
unbelievable breach and failure of of
security and Military I think part of
that can be apportioned to the
extraordinary social soci unrest that's
been enveloping Israel since his cabinet
full of a lot of right-wing heg bangers
frankly some of whom have actually call
themselves fascists uh have tried to
take on the Judiciary and the Supreme
Court I don't feel comfortable about
that what do you feel about that and do
you feel that Netanyahu is the right
person should does it need a completely
clean leadership now both in Palestine
and Israel to try and get to somewhere
approaching peace the democratically
elected govern of Israel has not had a
change in policy despite the fact that
until very recently Netanyahu was not
the prime minister of Israel it was a
joint government run by naali Bennett as
well as by yayer Leed who's a member of
the hard left who dramatically opposes
Benjamin Netanyahu today they formed a
Unity government between Benny gon who's
a member of the center left and Benjamin
Netanyahu who's a member of the Central
right leud party in Israel this is not
when it comes to foreign policy the
reality is that since the rejection of
any peace deal by Mahmud abas in 2009
when Aur was the Prime Minister of
Israel there's been very little
disagreement between any of the parties
with regard to foreign policy because
they do not have a peace partner the Osa
process was killed by the Palestinians
and it was killed by the Palestinians
when they rejected multiple peace
offerings by AUD Barack by Ariel Chiron
by AUD om over and over and over again
by Yak Rabin by Shimon Perez Benjamin
Netanyahu himself in the wi River
Accords of 1998 handed over significant
portions of the West Bank to the
Palestinians so you can say that
Netanyahu is a problem that's fine but
the reality I was asking you whether I
was asking you whether you feel
he is a problem that actually all the
division that's been caused by his
attempt to usurp the power of the
Supreme Court as many people see it all
that division in Israel has actually
diminished his authority uh and that has
come at a time when you really need
somebody with real Authority well I mean
I I don't think that right now that's
really the question considering again
it's a Unity government and I'm talking
to everybody in Israel and all of those
divisions heal up in a moment when your
children are being slaughtered at the
border as it turns out so you know all
of the judicial reform conversation is a
separate conversation we can critique
how fast they went in terms of this
Coalition they went too fast they scaled
it back there were serious divisions in
Israeli Society about what kind of power
the Judiciary ought to have there are
many people on both sides actually who
believe the Judiciary had too much power
there are a lot of people on both sides
who believe the government went too fast
on that internal political divisions
have become completely irrelevant here
if if Netanyahu were replaced tomorrow
by Benny gon which is what a lot of
Israelis would hope for if if that were
to happen literally tomorrow nothing
would
reason because this issue this
particular issue isas this has tocy of
the Israeli government you could find
the most left-wing person in in Israeli
politics right now which would be Ariel
Leed you could put him back in the Prime
Minister seat and he would be forced
with exactly the same decisions that
Netanyahu is faced with right now how do
you see to take me forward 20 years in a
dream
scenario how does the region look in a
dream scenario Economic Development
which I think is what the Abraham
Accords were about and what the
burgeoning Saudi peace deal was about
and by the way the burgeoning Saudi
peace deal is the reason that Hamas did
this at the beest of Iran they were
afraid of a regional realignment that
would create a Sunni Jewish Alliance
right oriented largely against the the
the Shia power of Iran which is spread
through Lebanon Syria and now down into
into kamasan uh the the you know the
economic development is the only way to
move forward for the region that was the
premise of the abrahamic again it was
the premise of the the nent Saudi peace
deal Israel would love to do that with
the Palestinian Authority they would
love to do that with with anyone
governing the Palestinians to provide
better economic conditions I one of the
great ironies of all this is that 20% of
Israel's population is Arab the the
Arabs in Israel earn a far better income
they they have far better GDP per capita
than Arabs who are living under the
Palestinian Authority or under the Gaza
or under the or under Hamas and when you
take polls of Israeli Arabs many of whom
are not particularly fond of the state
of Israel almost zero of them wish to
actually relocate to any of these areas
because economic development is economic
development the the way out of this is
that but in order for that to happen the
people on the other side of the table
have to actually agree that economic
development is a worthwhile thing is an
end goal and this goes back to the
original point that I was making is that
we in the west we believe that Economic
Development worthwhile that what we are
all seeking is the same sort of peaceful
decent life where we leave each other
alone and get to live our lives I think
that we all we all agree on that but
there's a group of people who absolutely
do not agree with that and they don't
care about the level of Economic
Development they would rather live I
mean Hamas would rather that its own
citizens live in poverty and penury and
Orient themselves against the external
of the Jews that Economic Development
even be allowed to take place I
mean I promise you everyone in the
Israeli government right to left would
love nothing better than economic
development of the people surrounding
them so they don't have to send their
sons and daughters to go fight and die
in Gaza do you believe in the concept of
a two-state
solution I mean if there were a party on
the other side to negotiate with and if
there if the if the possibility of a
two-state solution was real sure I mean
but the question is how realistic is
that negotiations cannot be the the the
Cure All you can't you have to have a
partner on the other side of the table
the entire premise of the Osa Accords is
that you could take an actual terrorist
by the name of yasar Arafat you could
you could negotiate with him you could
make a deal with him and this would
magically cure the situation well a deal
is not capable of being cut with with
literally anyone that's not the way any
of this works so in order for there to
be any sort of long-term peace including
a Palestinian State there would have to
be a complete difference in in
leadership in in these areas and that
would actually require Palestinian
moderates to take the four the
Palestinian Authority is not a is not a
moderate group Islamic Jihad is a
terrorist group Hamas is a terrorist
group and until that changes nothing's
going to change and by the way there is
the possibility of that change if you
had told me 10 years ago that there
would be Saudi Israeli normalization on
the table I would have laughed in your
face if you told me that Israel would
been able to cut peace deals with the
UAE and with Morocco I I would have I
would have scoffed and I think everyone
would have scoffed so there is that
possibility but again you cannot make
peace with aide that wants to murder you
that is not a possibility well on that
Point all I would say to that is I'm an
Irish Catholic and we had the troubles
in Northern Ireland different
circumstances I'm not going to try and
equate the two uh but there you had
people on both sides trying to kill each
other you had the IRA trying to kill
civilians uh indiscriminately to make
their political points and in the end a
peace deal was achieved but it was
achieved by people sitting down opposite
people they knew had been killing
civilians and killing people on their
side you even had the queen meeting
Martin mcginness and Jerry Adams who
were the uh you know in mcguinness's
case the former Chief of Staff of the
IRA ordered some of the most appalling
atrocities the queen one of her own
relatives was blown to Pieces Lord mount
baton by the IRA but she still met with
them I was actually at number 10 Downing
Street when Tony Blair met mcginness and
Adams on the steps for the first time in
in 70 years uh as the members of shim
Fain and shook their hands I was next in
to see him in his office and it was an
extraordinary moment to watch and it was
a moment many people thought would never
happen um do you see any parallel there
in terms of what could be achieved with
Israel and Palestine only if the
leadership changes only if the
leadership changes on the Palestinian
side that is the only way that happens
and again the the the difference here is
that the IRA had territorial Ambitions
Kamas does not have territorial
Ambitions they have genocidal Ambitions
the Palestinian Authority has been
offered multiple deals over multiple
decades and they' have rejected without
counter offers virtually every deal
they' have ever been offered Islamic
Jihad is a terrorist group again if if
the IRA was dedicated to the complete
Slaughter and eradication of every
non-irish britisher in the UK that would
be the equivalent of Hamas and that
would not be a negotiating position
because again could there be successful
negotiations with it depends on it
depends on the partner right that the
example that you're using is is the best
example of sides that are incredibly far
apart coming together but here we are
talking about one side that simple
premise if Israel put down all of its
guns tomorrow every Jew in the region
would be slaughtered if Hamas put down
all of its guns tomorrow Israel would
leave the Gaza Strip alone it is that
simple let me ask you you got into a a
Twitter spat with Andrew Tate yesterday
he's a converted Muslim he'd been doing
a lot of uh supportive tweets uh for the
Palestinians and he tweeted at one stage
Mr tough guy let me assure you as
someone who's done his own fighting as
opposed to excitedly encouraging others
to do it for him while sitting at home
on a comfy chair peace is always worth a
conversation what what was that spat
about why did you engage with him what
do you feel about that well what I feel
about that is that he was tweeting that
immediately like as terrorists were
still running around in southern Israel
that was on October 10th and he was
still Tweeting while the bodies were
fresh and warm in the streets peace is
you cannot make peace with people who
murdered your children and burned their
bodies you can't do that I mean this
this rush to Israel I I the murder
happens and you immediately say okay
well guys now truce now truce now
ceasefire that is not no State worth its
salt no government on Earth would allow
this kind of insanity no government on
Earth and no government on Earth would
listen to nonsense about how you
immediately have to seek peace with a
group that seeks your direct
extermination again I I can't emphasize
enough Israel turned over the Gaza Strip
to gazans in 2005 Hamas has governed the
area since 2006 the year is currently
20123 Israel has has endured round after
round of Rocket fire on its major I for
literally almost years and now the idea
is the minute that g gazen terrorists
rush through the border and murder
people in their beds that's the Time For
Peace conversation that's the Time For
Peace conversation by the way and I'm
not gonna be lectured on morality and
toughness by by Andrew Tate whose great
idea of toughness and morality is
pimping women and then bragging about it
on air and and trying to quasy walk it
back while simultaneously maintaining
many of the same positions and flexing
his
biceps I mean he's got a huge following
as you know especially online is it is
it dangerous is it Reckless that he's
able to tweet from house arrest still of
course in Romania that he can tweet on
something like this and have the kind of
influence that he has listen everyone
should be able to tweet whatever it is
that they want them all for an open
discourse even with people who I think
are dead wrong on a lot of these issues
but Andrew Tate is dead wrong on a lot
of these issues and and the the
particularly ridiculous posturing about
being a yes you're very yes you're very
tough when when you want people to make
peace with with terrorists who just
murder their children very very
tough you mentioned Iran earlier
President Biden yesterday came out
10-minute speech you know sounded very
tough and very supportive of Israel but
never once mentioned Iran was that a a
failure by him or are they waiting to
establish concrete evidence of Iran's
involvement no I think there's a good
reason he could have done that and a bad
reason that he could have done that and
the the bad reason is pretty obvious
which is that the United States has
unfrozen six billion dollars in assets
to to flood into Iran in return for
hostages that money is fungible and
there's every possibility that money
flowing into Iran since since the
weakening of sanctions has contributed
to Iran's spread of Terror that is not
only a possibility that's a probability
and everyone knows it so if you avoid
mentioning Iran then presumably it
avoids blowback that is the bad reason
the good reason might be that the United
States wants to take down the
temperature in the region so right now
geopolitically this is a contained
conflict this is Israel versus Hamas in
the Gaza Strip and everyone of good
heart on every side should hope that it
remains that way if Hezbollah which is
on Israel's northern border and an
Iranian client Hezbollah is a massive
and significantly more powerful thanas
terrorist group that exists and and has
say in the government of Lebanon again
Israel is surrounded on a lot of sides
by terrorist groups that mate his
government Hezbollah has about 150,000
much more sophisticated Rockets than
than Hamas pointed at Northern Israel
everyone understands that if Hezbollah
which would only do this at the P of
Iran if if Hezbollah were to get in
Israel would then be stretched
militarily to the point where they would
not have any choice but to go full force
and what that means is that all of the
talk right now about the the supposed
disproportionate force that Israel is
using in the Gaza Strip talk with which
I wildly disagree uh that that will all
go out the window because once you are
stretched to the point of
extermination all bets are off and and
the Israeli Air Force will have to be
Unleashed on the on the southern border
of Lebanon at that point you wouldd have
to imagine that that Bashar Assad in
Syria starts to get active Iran starts
to get active so one of the things that
that the possible good reason why he
didn't mention Iran is because he's
attempting to keep Iran out of the war
that basically the idea would be he did
say in the speech that any other group
that wants to get in don't America to
its great credit to our great credit
we've stationed a battle carrier an
aircraft carrier outside of uh outside
of Lebanon in the Mediterranean and
basically said tobah that they should
not get in uh that is in fact the best
available move so again there's a very
plausible bad reason why he didn't
mention Iran which is to avoid the
blowback from his own idiotic Iran
policy and there's a possible good
reason which is that he's attempting to
avoid the broadening of the conflict
Donald Trump says as he's want to do
with these crises that would never have
happened if he was President do you
think that may have some truth I think
there's some truth to that for sure I
think that that that Iran has seen
weakness Iran saw an opportunity to to
prevent the Saudis from coming into to
the Abraham Accords and uh they thought
that they could push where they saw mush
I mean the withdrawal from Afghanistan
made America look weak The Continuous
dealings between the United States and
Iran despite Iran's openly genocidal
intentions with regard to Israel has
made America look weak the fact that
Robert Mali who is one of the chief
negotiators the United States was
apparently co-opted by Iranian
intelligence groups makes the Americans
look look particularly weak and so
appearances of weakness in the Middle
East matter an awful lot it is it is not
politics in western states you where
where we try to negotiate we try to have
discussions that is not how politics
works in the Middle East it is a place
where strength is is really the only
coin of the realm there is a theory that
Hamas have done this spectacularly awful
Act of terrorism deliberately on a scale
that would go Israel into
overreacting and Spark a much a much
wider
War I mean I think that there's probably
truth to that I think that that Hamas I
think that's what ran wants I'm not sure
that Hamas wanted that I think Hamas uh
doesn't want to be wiped off the Earth
which they probably will be and ought to
be um but I think that that Iran's Hope
was that Israel would have to go in
incredibly strong as the Gaza Strip and
this would provide internal pressure in
Saudi Arabia to prevent them from
forming an alliance brokered by the
Americans with the Israelis I think that
was probably the geop political reason
for that with that said that does not
mean that Israel has any other choice
again if if suddenly 1500 terrorists
flooded into Great Britain and proceeded
to murder 15 to 20,000 people because
again Israel is a tiny tiny country it
has n million people if if those numbers
were made proportionate if if tens of
thousands of people were slaughtered in
Britain by a group of terrorists I doubt
that there' be a lot of British citizens
who are sitting around worrying about
proportionality or worrying about the
geopolitical consequences of protecting
their own citizenry there is an
interesting uh contradiction I would
argue that a lot of uh conservatives in
America a lot of
Republicans have including a number of
presidential candidates from Ronda
santis to Trump uh and others um they
have signaled that they would want to
severely curtail if not stop allog
together support for Ukraine and yet
Ukraine was invaded um by Russia um a
lot of people slaughtered contined to be
slaughtered um is there not a
contradiction there that these
Republicans would be I mean yes full
Square behind Israel when it happens to
them but not full Square behind
Ukraine I mean yes there is a
contradiction it depends on on sort of
what is being said about Ukraine and it
runs the gamut and some of the
candidates that you've talked about have
talked about ending Aid completely to
Ukraine some have talked about
continuing Aid to Ukraine and and
pursuing some sort of of deal with the
Russians that allows them to keep part
of the dabass and Crimea which I think
is a completely different story and and
is an actual off-ramp um but yes anybody
who is who is you know sympathetic to
Russia in the Russia Ukraine conflict
and then it's sympathetic to Israel in
this current conflict that that is a a
bizarre position to take again I think
they serious America is a sovereign
country it has its own concerns that are
not Israel's concerns and it has its own
concerns that are not Ukraine's concerns
and those Z those zones always line up
um but when it comes to you know a
possible contradiction between a
completely isolationist position on
Ukraine and a an interventionist
position or supporter position on Israel
of course those things could could
clearly be in Conflict my own position
by the way on for what it's worth since
I yeah as you know be I do this for a
living uh my own position on Ukraine has
been that the United States should
continue to supply Ukraine with the
support necessary in order to preserve
its government and to preserve its
territory and meanwhile there need to be
serious talks about what exactly an
offramp looks like in Ukraine because
virtually no one has spelled out exactly
what that looks like and fortunately No
One Believes at this point Ukraine is
going to be able to completely take back
both the donbass and and the Crimea
region that that is very complicated
having been to Ukraine and interviewed
president zalinski met a lot of people
there and that was quite a while ago uh
there was an unbelievably Steely resolve
and I would I would say the same resolve
that Israel has about seeding any land
now to the Palestinians it's like they
just don't want to give an inch of land
away to the Russians um that was to a
man and woman that I met out there I
have an enormous amount of sympathy for
that position again that that that
position does not necessarily dictate
American policy anymore than than
Israel's position with regard to say the
the so called occupied territories
disputed territories should necessarily
dictate America's position on that the
they realistic consequences and concerns
to be had on foreign policy um but if
the point that you're making is that
lack of moral support in an invasion of
a sovereign country by by Russia is in
contradiction with moral support for
Israel in this I I would say yeah I mean
there's certainly inconsistency there I
mean the other inconsistency and
contradiction it seems to me is the
reaction of the world when George Floyd
was murdered which was a Despicable
killing and the police officer concerned
uh is now serving a life sentence quite
rightly but that
sparked enormous Global protests uh Over
America over the UK everywhere uh with
people Marching In protest at what they
perceive to be a racist murder of one
person and yet the reaction within hours
of what happened here where as we knew
at the time nearly a thousand people in
Israel had been murdered uh some in the
most utterly horrific
circumstances um the reaction was that
yes there were big protests again but
they weren't really protests they were
marches of
celebration in America in UK they
marched down my local High Street uh
celebrating what had happened Pro
Palestinian marches I found that
extraordinary Jew hatred is a very real
thing it's a very real thing and and
we've obscured it with a lot of talk
about Zionism and anti-zionism and we've
scared it with a lot of talk about
geopolitics and context but in the end
Jew hatred is quite real and when you
see crowds in Sydney chaning gas the
Jews not free the occupied territories
not make a peace deal gas the Jews I'm
not sure what we're supposed to read
into that other than people mean what
they say when they say gas the Jews yeah
I mean that's exactly what they mean I
mean this is this is Nazi language I
mean but as you say the difference
between this and the Nazis the Nazis
tried to keep the secret um whereas this
is all in plain sight I mean the idea of
people doing this in cities like Sydney
and London and New York it's it's uh
it's actually terrifying and I say that
again I'm an Irish Catholic I'm not
Jewish uh I feel terrified for Jewish
people like you say there's only 15
million Jewish people in the world uh it
must be when this kind of thing happens
in such an indiscriminate manner it must
be genuinely terrifying for people for
sure and and obviously when you see
marches of support it it the the
question is always asked how could the
Holocaust have happened and the answer
is this way when people are are actively
in favor of Jews being murdered simply
for for being Jews and again it's easy
to people people have an amazing ability
to to justify whatever it is that
they're thinking or feeling at a given
time but if you can find a way to
justify yourself out of the the murder
of of babies in their cribs I I have a I
have a hard time figuring that it's
anything other than Jew hatred and so if
you know as a Jew as a person who you
know is very strongly Jewish I'm very
active in my Jewish Community as a
person with four kids and and a wife and
parents and sisters and and all of this
you know obviously Jews feel like they
are at risk everywhere because of of of
this sort of activity and and I will say
there's an amazing double standard when
it comes to anti-Semitism and its
treatment in the media the way that it
seems to work in the media these days is
if a if if somebody politically says
something about George Soros then they
will be labeled the Nazi and if somebody
actually says I anzi then they will say
well there's probably some sort of
justification over territorial disputes
yeah I want to end Ben uh on a one
positive note and it's a montage we have
of support for uh the Jewish people and
for Israel let's take a
look
so Ben that last image was of the
Brandenburg gate which of course we saw
back in the 30s with Nazi swers all over
it and today the Israel flag is
emblazened uh across it proudly and
supportively I mean amid all the Jew
hating and you're right that's what it
is there's also been an amazing
outpouring of
Po and that is incredible and we who are
Jews obviously appreciate that and um I
would just like to say at the very end
here that that must be translated into
allowing Israel to do what must be done
to protect her own citizenry because
Goodwill only goes so far as the actual
protection of of human lives and uh if
the Jews were to rely on The Good Will
of the world over the course of history
it would have gone very poorly for them
that's why the state of Israel exists it
exists it never again is never again and
in order for that to be reality the the
IDF the state of Israel has to be able
to defend itself has to be able to
defend its citizenry and protect them
from the kind of Slaughter and and
savagery that we saw over the weekend
benir thank you very much indeed for
your time today I appreciate it thank
you